let's solve this practice question the  angle shown are acute and sine of a  degrees is equal to the cosine of B  degrees if a equals 4K minus 21 and b  equals 6K minus 13 what is the value of  K  the first thing we'll do is we'll  eliminate the diagram in this question  because it's just a waste of time  we are given that the sine of a degrees  is equal to the cosine of B degrees and  the angles are acute  now we always have the identity that the  sine of a degrees is equal to the cosine  of 90 degrees minus 8 degrees  we add the given information that this  equals the cosine of B degrees  from here we can conclude that 90 minus  a is equal to B  then we substitute in for a and b  is equal to 6K minus 13 and a is equal  to 4K minus 21. we then just carefully  simplify and we get the correct answer  that K is equal to 12.4